In this unit, we're going to talk about forms and how you get data
from your browser to a web server, and we're not going to spend a whole lot of time here
on the sketch pad today, but first things first.
What I want you to do is open a text file in your editor of choice
and put some text in it.
I'm in my editor here, and I'm just going to add some text, kind of standard text.
I save this file as play.html,
and the next thing I want you to do is open this file in your web browser of choice.
What we have here is the text that I entered in the editor here in the browser,
and if we were to go back to the editor and change something--
we'll change our word here--save it and then go back to the browser and reload,
you can see it live updates, so this is a handy way for kind of
playing with and experimenting with HTML in a real browser,
and we're going to be doing a fair amount of this today.
The first thing I want to teach you about is HTML forms
and the elements required to make them.
We have another tag called "form," and it looks like this.
And like many HTML tags, it has a closing form.
We're going to go back and forth here, between our editor and our browser
and here while I'm explaining things.
Let's enter this in our editor.
Here we are in our editor.
I'm going to replace this text with that basic HTML tag I just showed you,
.
Okay, there we go.
We're going to save this, and we're going to go back to our browser and reload the page.
Nothing is there. And why is that?
Because we didn't enter any content.
Let's talk about the content that goes in an HTML form.
There are a few things that can go in here, one of which is an element called input,
which looks like this.
Let's enter that in our HTML editor.
Okay, now we go back to our browser, and we reload this.
A-ha.
Now we have an input box, and we can type things in this box.
Pretty cool, huh?
The input tag can take a couple of attributes,
one of which is called "name," and name looks like this.
It's like all attributes.
We have the actual attribute, which in this case is called "name,"
and then the value, which I've written here in red.
This can be whatever we want.